the late night host stephen colbert a
left winger
sees no difference between american
conservatives and the taliban
he's right
we've had troops there for 20 years
they fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack
in america planned in a foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
got our own on capitol hill january 6th
you know the insurrection you know
remember that the worst coup d'etat in
american history because the horn guy
danced around the capital you remember
because the smiley guy took pelosi's
lectern
ridiculous ridiculous
in in
comparison to the actions of the taliban
or al-qaeda
of course the january 6th people
did absolutely nothing
in comparison to american leftists in
2020 the january six people did
absolutely nothing you're right we do
have insurrectionists and terrorists in
the country they burned down they burned
down multiple cities during 2020
including federal courthouses and police
stations and
private businesses and private homes and
they killed a lot of people
and they were all on the left and they
all got a pass and they're all protected
by the regime is it any wonder we're so
divided
this is how they feel though it's
perfectly fine for the left to do that
because the left is part of the regime
and the right can't do that because the
right is out the right is
scapegoated and ostracized
hey i'm glad you liked that clip i hope
you liked that clip if you did just
leave a comment just say hey michael i
like that clip that'd be nice i
appreciate that it makes me feel good
if you have not subscribed please do
here at youtube but also to the michael
now show podcast on apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you